Let's look more formally at
what Cloud computing provides.
Traditionally businesses would buy and
configure the resources that
are needed for their services.
How many resources should be
purchased and configured?
So what is the capacity
of those resources?
Well that typically would be based on
some expectations regarding the demand
for that particular business, for
that particular service,
typically considering the peak demand.
So if we have a situation in which
the Demand follows this pink or
this red line, then the business
would configure their resources,
their capacity,
based on this blue line, so
that it can tolerate the expected
peak in the service demand.
Now the expectations turn out
to be not quite accurate and
the demand ends up exceeding
the provision capacity.
The business will end up with
a situation in which requests have
to be dropped and
there will be a lost opportunity.
In the case of given the very
rapid spike in the workload,
this lost opportunity would
have been tremendous.
Instead, what we would like
would be the ideal case
is if the following were to happen.
The capacity or the available resources
should scale elastically with the demand
and the scaling should be instantaneous.
As soon as the demand increases,
the capacity should increase too.
And then in the other direction, too,
as soon as the demand decreases
the capacity should decrease as well.
Meaning that the cost to operate
these resources, the cost to support
this service should be proportional to
the demand to the revenue opportunity.
All of this should happen
automatically without the need for
some hacking wizardry.
And all these resources can be
accessed anytime from anywhere.
One potential [INAUDIBLE] here
is that you wouldn't necessarily
own these resources that
magically appear on demand.
But that may be something that
you're willing to compromise on
provided that you really do
achieve these kinds of benefits.
And that there is some kind of
proper assurance as to what exactly
can possibly go wrong with these
resources that you're accessing.
So the goal of Cloud Computing is
to provide these capabilities that
match the idea scenario
as much as possible.
The resulting requirements
can be distilled as follows.
Cloud computing should provide on
demand, elastic resources and services.
There should be fine-grained
pricing based on usage.
Not for actual or
potentially idle physical
servers like in the hosting data centers
that were the alternative at the time.
All the resources should be
professionally managed and hosted.
And all of this should be available via
APIs that can be used for remote access.